Stacy Abrams has been hammered on this  issue of defund the police just like all  the Democrats have and she's she's just  denying it she says I've never wanted to  defund the police I've always been  completely opposed to defunding the  police the record doesn't reflect that  though I did not say and nor do I  believe in defunding the police he is  lying again and I've never said that I  believe in defunding the police so yes  to some defunding we have to reallocate  resources so yes there it is so yes to  defunding the police yeah we need to  reallocate resources so yes defund the  police I've never said I would defund  the police lady we have videotape okay  and I know the Democrats try to memory  hole all of this stuff but we still can  get access to it all right we can work a  little Wizardry on the internet we can  pull it up the people are not going to  be fooled forever